There are four people in the house now, and I'm very happy.
And Jane?
Well, we all like her.
Morning everybody.
What's this?
It's a video film about my new house and my new housemates.
It's for my sister, Alison.
Oh, right.
Is it OK?
Yeah, sure.
Ok, Ali.
This is the kitchen.
And who is this?
Say something.
Say what?
It's half past seven in the morning.
Talk to my sister.
Introduce yourself.
Go on, David.
Hello, I'm David.
I come from Manchester.
I'm a lawyer.
I work in Oxford.
That's it.
What things do you like?
I like my job.
I like football, swimming.
I like a quiet breakfast,...
...and I don't like video cameras...
...and I start work at eight o'clock.
So, bye.
Bye.
David's nice, really.